je vais essayer de vous parler de mon
expérience personnelle
est différente les sur celles de
messieurs 1
et aussi un peu différente de celle de
souvenirs propre et quoique aussi j'ai
rendu de leurs de terre est jeune mais
elle perd sa maman mais j'ai pas réussi
parce que j'ai en fait comme il rêvait
quand un gamin de 10 ans en essayer
devant des chenilles et qu'une petite
fille de lui demande de lui donner
gratuitement c'est assez difficile donc
de temps que je fais commencé par
raconter mon histoire en tant qu'enfant
donc étant jeune
gêné chose qui n'a rien quoi donc j'ai
beaucoup la mission française
je voulais faire partie d'un me semble
c'était mon rêve et ça avait l'air
vraiment très très beau ou comparé au
lycée l'école et avait l'air bien
bien organisés les gens étaient bien
habillés et tout ça est donc mort encore
que goss et de julie d'être lisse et des
cas si tout ce que je voulais donc ça a
commencé comme simple entraînement au
grand frère a en fait et or
les idk et ça n'a fait qu'augmenter ma
frustration puisque je les ai pourquoi
pas moi ensuite donc vient l'époque où
je devais avoir dans les 16 17 ans et là
je dis j'aime mon père je ne peux pas
pas j'aimerais rentrer à la mission
parce que là j'aimerais qu'on fasse
quelque chose parce que trop tard
et du coup on l'a on a décidé ensemble
que j'allais partir en france donc chez
mon frère qui était à sophia antipolis
donc l'école de commerce un peu
la chaîne s'appelle de y yo l'ont repéré
qu'un institut australie donc je vais je
vais chez mon frère vit vraiment ma part
je débarque directement dans un lycée
catholique qui s'appelle des 10 et du
mans saint jean à antibes
pas moins de dix donc marocain que je
suis à l'âge de 17 ans avec les cheveux
décolorés
donc voilà l'année du bac
ensuite je réussis mon année et du goût
j'étais un peu comment dire écart et je
serai demain je ne savais pas vraiment
quoi faire de malfi est ce que j'avais
fait étendre mais on parlait tout le
temps de commerce commerce tout le monde
de faire du commerce business management
marchetti je ne suis je pas la même
chose donc si on fait à sophia antipolis
au yoyo avec les étudiants y dans mon
grand frère était et sophia antipolis en
fait c'est comment dire une technopole
avait beaucoup d'écoles mais en fait
sûrement déjà d'une forêt à queue avec
en fait beaucoup d'efforts et la forêt
de s'identifier et pour moi ce que
j'adore gagner à l'époque c'est sortir
du coup aller dans la forêt et chanter
et je profite en fait je l'imaginé que
les armes étaient des spectateurs donc
déjà 18 19 ans
tibi est beaucoup plus intéressés par la
musique et tout ce qui est musique soul
euh sinon la clé ce qui n'a rien à
vendre et donc là je me suis dit qu'est
ce que tu aimerais faire de ta vie
sexuelle préfère du restant de et
j'arrive vraiment pas mais vraiment pas
à à savoir ce que je voulais faire et
donc je suis rentré pour les vacances au
maroc
je devais avoir dix huit ans dans le
pays 19 ans donc les vacances de milieu
d'année et c'est là où j'ai vu une
ginisty les trois films de gilles simon
est grand donc la fureur de vivre à
l'est d'éden et géo
quand j'ai vu djezzy à l'écran j'ai su
que c'était ce que je voulais faire en
fait c'était vraiment simple james dean
fortin qui est mort à l'âge de 24 ans
dans un terrible hâtivement qui avait
vraiment une prestance une présence
que moult acteurs n'ont pas réussi à
avoir pendant des centaines d'années
mais juste par ses trois fils
comment il a réussi en même pas trois
quatre ans à conquérir les états unis à
venir cette idole comment dire universal
les réponses et donc quand j'ai pu avec
sa petite veste rouge et je suis
vraiment vraiment identifié et donc je
suis reparti en france
mon père m'a dit qu'est ce que tu veux
faire je dis que tu m as peur tu sais
comme acteur ça métier et j'ai dit rien
à faire je vais aller real est donc
parti en france
j'ai commencé par faire une école qui
s'appelle l'écart
l'école internationale de création
audiovisuelle
a sion la stib a dit à paris ensuite
j'en ai parlé un peu la famille et mon
nom qui agent comptable à lyon m'a dit
mon fils si tu veux être acteur c'est au
cours florent qu'il faut aller et c'est
comme ça je me suis retrouvé ou florent
donc j'ai passé quatre années au flore
en trois ans normalement mais comme j'ai
géré gérer j'ai rajouté un an après et
c'est pendant cette quatrième année
comme a proposé de rencontrer monsieur
votre part et donc à ras bord à casa
negra et on va aussi proposer en même
temps et ça je ne le dit pas mais au
bout bien je ne dis pas souvent vous
rappelle que je n'ai jamais dit mais
intégré la comédie française mais j'ai
préféré en faire rentrer dans mon pays
au lieu de rester travailler dans la
comédie française peut-être que j'aurais
pu avoir 2000 ou 3000 euros par mois en
étant un acteur
de police en train de pousser un
accessoire ou quelque chose non j'ai
préféré rentrer au maroc et à voir
l'intérieur que j'ai eu un vrai site
je dirais c'est relatif vraiment n'avait
il a récité très relative par exemple en
temps quand on quand on parle on me voit
comme ça en disant oui c'est l'acteur
d'accord mais qu'est-ce capables par
exemple la réussite qu'est ce que la
réussite est ce que c'est la vraie si
régulières ou est-ce que vers la
réussite personnelle
moi j'ai préféré la réussite personnelle
c'est-à-dire la réussite faire ce que
j'aime et nous réveiller matin heureux
pour faire un boulot qui sera peut-être
mal payés ou pas mais qui sera le boulot
que j'ai décidé de faire équipe au top
du plaisir quand je quand je fais
tourner ou que je viens faire mon
travail que je suis vraiment vraiment
content de faire et je pense que c'est
c'est plus important que l'argent ggg
pas de projet pas de trucs super et
hyper intéressant à vous dire mais voilà
c'est ma petite expérience
merci d'avoir écouté